hello and welcome to this video a blitz
game on leech s so what do we do hmm I
can do something non theoretical for a
change
and see what happens kind of a it's
probably a Tori Tori yeah it's a very
healthy set up so I should be should be
okay yeah just developing pieces the
natural squares
yeah I'm not certain about this one
but it's generally an active diagonal
and maybe he feels like weakening
himself would be five you never know
yeah this is an idea yeah I was
wondering about this
this should probably help like to
equalize some 97 and c5 but okay my
development is definitely okay so okay
he wants to go Bishop d5 so that's
castle okay
am threatening group takes is six now
strategically dangerous exchange like
this is a weird move running right into
this one with tempo now you can
basically go back where is he going
Queen to c7 hmm no yeah I don't know if
c5 is on the radar and Bishop b3 hmm
yeah let let's do this I mean he
basically it probably has to take now
more or less and then I can take with
the a pawn which is a small
accomplishment not much but it's it's
noise the ideal would be to play b4 and
make c5 yeah
prevent c5 that should give me a small
advantage long-term small advantage all
right
I wonder if I should go Knight see form
it is an interesting idea let's do it
the knight is generally well placed here
and maybe I get to like place a bishop
on to d6 and irritate him okay yeah
let's go him
the the black the slight issue that he's
facing as I said he has a problem with
his palm breaks it doesn't get the
desired palm breaks and with the e pawn
or with the C pawn okay now it seems he
is I were to play e5 something like
Queen f3 and Bishop f6 that would be
nice
the play Queen e2 probably rook e8 will
happen and he will continue to stop this
ism does this prevents e5 more or less
because a bishop g3 would be very
annoying then I just want to make sure
okay so it doesn't mind mmm no not
certain that this was a good choice by
black if I go is Queen e2 okay okay I
mean is it is it a good move
let's try I can actually no yeah what is
this what is this reply then I mean f6
is a strategically terrible move and
this is not a huge help
it's really surprised that he went d5 I
mean Bishop h5 my intentions were very
clear
okay now mm f4 almost impossible I mean
I'm just better of course after
capturing and Knight reform that's
basically an eternal advantage with the
knight on e4 against that lousy Bishop
you know no no I want to the light
squares are key here I don't want to
take this is better
yeah now the question is it a question
if I check here and then take it must be
excellent right now that is fine now in
Knight to c4 is absolutely ideal if I
can manage okay - probably on itv4
headset that's a bit of an ok so I will
put the Queen here and the Knight to c4
them
if or it's not it's not totally simple
and but now f5 should be gone more or
less
yeah the the good thing is that this is
right on c4 is such a beast it covers
everything at xe5 yeah like resigned you
know that was a bit of a strategic
disaster after he stepped into the c5
thing okay we had a fairly normal
position maybe I don't know if that was
a good choice because this this kind of
central transformation should be a
generally quite okay for black I would
probably prefer to play 97 in this
position and prepare c5 I mean that is
not a mistake but I don't think it's the
best possible way to play rook e1 Knight
f6 Bishop c2 and this is an interesting
moment because I'm absolutely
threatening rook takes c6 so if for
example what stockfish is suggesting
here move like a 5 I will just take him
and this is a very nice position for
white that pawn is basically yeah going
to going to be lost and I have two
bishops the light squares are fantastic
it's it's it's it's nice to see that
stockfish even had a very modest depth
is immediately recognized that white is
quite substantially better I I once made
a video on my channel years ago called
I think automatic sacrifice or something
based on a game tal with white against
Tom I think it was playing a Bulgarian
player where we did it's almost exactly
the same thing
okay black stop that and now I went
Bishop b3 which more or less entice him
to take because I'm threatening to
capture here and
discovery so takes and now upon takes
that gives a little bit more a little
bit more ideas and now this is
interesting the engine recommends a five
there is some point to that after each
six before I'm definitely better it's
not really am it's pretty clear that
white is better now because I'm stopping
all those porn breaks yeah you can
debate about ninety-five but it keeps
the pressure and this is an interesting
one and I'm happy Bishop age four is
also what the engine is having is one of
the top moves and it took me a while but
I think this is a strong move because II
five I want to prevent and this is
basically preventing e5 when you played
it anyway
so now after Bishop g3 you are in
trouble
you're just in this pin and f6 or such a
dreadful concession yeah him I hear the
engine already that's it's very true
give some this line where you just take
everything and then probably grab b7
this is of course excellent for white
yeah I didn't didn't do it I just put
more pressure on e5 and the way it
turned out this is again it's a disaster
really yeah now and on i-24 I wasn't
quite sure you can play it and in many
ways and and be better right away v went
b5 yeah and this looks fine here the
pawn structure is even the weak and now
alright ninety-four is probably more
powerful than you okay - mmm because
black cannot take it anyway because of
96 I guess yeah and I have this check
now the best possible outcome of course
would be the would be the always always
entertaining smothered mate okay we
played rukka - mmm in technical mode
here
Quincy for you just have this fantastic
advantage now things drop Niblick
resigned he's going to lose all the
points basically c6m e5 at least will
drop so what is interesting is this idea
to play be form that is important stops
this and the next one this is I'm really
happy with Bishop h4 I I stared at this
position for quite a while and couldn't
quite find a good solution the engine
also likes Queen d2 when they wonder
what the big ideas against c5 okay so
the engine just claims that this is also
an advantage okay I believe that because
this is just strong am I'm covering this
important square and you cannot get
really rid of this I have an easy idea
rookie to okay one okay this is also
better for white but Bishop h4 is I like
that I think it was a it was a it was a
neat idea okay guys thanks for watching